cutting-edge technology is helping
ancient Rome come back to life visitors
at historic sites thousands of years old
can now use virtual reality headsets to
see what they looked like digital
artists used Renaissance era art to
recreate the relics Seth Doane is inside
the ancient underground ruins in Rome
with how tourists can see what's no
longer there Seth good morning good
morning take a look at this this
cavernous space was once above-ground
the grand home of Emperor Nero and
considered one of the most magnificent
palaces ever built its name Duomo Saadia
means the golden house it's hard to
imagine that it was once colorful and
flooded with light but now modern
technology is allowing tourists to peer
into the past 2,000 years ago this
labyrinth now under the city of Rome was
the sprawling home of emperor Nero
stretching the size of three football
fields today tourists can explore it but
the colors light and opulence of this
ancient Roman villa were unimaginable
until this month when visitors could
start using virtual reality glasses the
room looked out centrally onto one of
the 2 pentagonal courtyards Tom Papa is
visiting from New York you always try
and imagine in your mind what it must
have been like and this helps
tremendously virtual reality brings to
life the Domus Aurea is grand
architecture rich colors and opulent
walls inlaid with precious gemstones all
of it had been lost for centuries this
entire room was filled with soil like
this yes and also other spaces and other
rooms we know now Alessandro D Alessio
the chief archaeologist here explained
how this place was buried following
Emperor Nero's death in the ancient
history ography he was depicted as a
monster as a monster the Emperor's
massive compound was covered over it was
forgotten
about for nearly 1,500 years until
Renaissance artists tunneled down into
what they believed was an ancient Roman
cave painters during Renaissance times
would come through that hole yes in
discovered the Domus Aurea
yes the marvellous frescoes they saw
influenced art for centuries and their
paintings of this site would become a
roadmap for a much later generation of
digital artists nothing is invented
nothing is invented every part of the
reconstruction as scientific beasts
Raphael a car Lonnie is an architect and
graphic designer whose company cata taxi
Luke's painstakingly created the virtual
reality show and you recognize from this
shape this really strange shape here so
you go back to these Renaissance
paintings to recreate what this looked
like yes and then to transition to here
digitally yes it's Italy so of course
his studio has its own frescoed ceiling
working from the town of Emilia outside
Rome designers used the graphically rich
technology of video games to virtually
transport tourists inside the ancient
drama Saadia to see its grandeur its
colourful marble and sweeping views of
Rome you look down at the grass and the
grass is moving in the wind this is
finally I saw a lot of children that try
to touch the grass it looks like
city of Rome has used technology to
reimagine several tourist sites
including the forums of Caesar and
Augustus where history is illuminated
through lasers and light shows projected
on the ruins through the virtual reality
you can understand how this space is
where in the past
Francesco prosperity is the
superintendent for archaeology in Rome
he was the one who pushed to use virtual
reality here it is something that nobody
can imagine before it's interesting this
concept of using modern technology to
understand ancient history to get closer
to these things of the other ancient
past the only way is to use technology
the architecture and paintings here
influenced the likes of Michelangelo and
Raphael excavation work here continues
there is still another 30% of this
palace to be unearthed
Wow that is just stunning I think so too